I call it the manual pause which is
mid-20s toward late 20s a lot of guys
realize that a lot of the values that
they hold a lot of the things that
previously they took a sense of
self-worth from that the world told them
that they should value they don't make
them feel fulfilled anymore and they go
I got toward the top of this mountain
and I realized that it was the wrong
Mountain that I climbed and actually I
was supposed to be on that one over
there and it's difficult because in
order to get to that one you need to go
back down this one that you've already
climbed this is where I think
introversion is such a cheat code
because the more frequently and the more
for a sustained period of time I'm
involved in certain just patterns of
behavior oftentimes socially or just
just what I do in general you just
become locked in those patterns and it
becomes more difficult you have more of
like a narrow perspective so for me a
lot of like the best insights that I've
gotten are like times when I like
completely just like fully detached and
just enter this weird like meditative
just like Flow State of just being just
so just alone because you're removing
the external inputs as best yeah
removing the inputs stopping the
behavior patterns just allowing yourself
to see things differently and have
different patterns